two days ago a British diplomat arrived
in Northeast Syria on a discreet
sensitive mission this is Martin London
he's Britain's special envoy to Syria
and he was here for a meeting which
would save the lives of a number of
British orphaned children many of the
details of his task which was completed
with the signing of a repatriation
document are still unable to be reported
the safety and security of the children
means we cannot identify them or any
details which could lead to their
identification but tonight following
this diplomatic handover the young
orphans are in bed in Britain a world
away from the Islamic state life they
were taken to they had arrived in Syria
in 2015
taken with many others from their UK
homes by their parents to the so called
Islamic state who knows quite what they
were exposed to there the extreme
atrocities of Isis beheadings executions
and the bombings of the coalition trying
to destroy the Caliphate their parents
died we don't know when or how it may
have been here the final battle in the
town of bagus in March those who weren't
killed were rounded up by the Kurdish
authorities the women and the children
were taken to two camps where they
remain and this is where the orphans
were found identified and in the past 48
hours extracted but as we discovered two
weeks ago there are still many hundreds
more children in these camps so what's
your name yourself and where are you
from Finland they are from all over the
world and they remain in this limbo
charities say there could be around 60
British youngsters still here somewhere
the conditions are grim and the only
guides in their lives are women the
mothers who we found still to be deeply
radicalized
I'm from these nuns page yeah but where
were you from before
the vast majority of the British
children remaining in Northeast Syria
are with their mothers those children
are no less innocent and no less
deserving of the opportunity to be
brought home to the UK to safely recover
so where what needs to happen now is an
urgent repatriation of all of those
children as well a statement from
someone close to the operation to
extract the children said tonight they
slept peacefully in the car on the
journey from the airport they
immediately recognized the family
members and family home on their arrival
they've settled into the home and
appeared to be as happy as they possibly
could be in the difficult circumstances
of their return and from the Prime
Minister this evening this the situation
in Syria is very difficult and very
dangerous and I think it's been a great
success that some orphaned children have
been brought back but I think it would
be you know it would be over-optimistic
frankly to say that we can do it in
every single case the military and
logistical difficulties involved are
very considerable but what I've said is
that where the government can help then
it should help but holding these women
and children here and the men in the
jail's is simply not sustainable we were
told that repeatedly by the Kurdish
officials guarding them some need
prosecuting some rescuing and yet with
the exception of some vulnerable
individuals there is no plan globally
for how to solve this Mark Stone Sky
News